[Música]
[Aplausos]
estuve pensando mucho en la mejor forma
la forma más clara de poder crear en
ustedes
desde el contar mi experiencia de vida
el interés por preguntarse por qué debo
ser donante
estoy casada tengo un hijo de 24 años
y a los nueve años tuve una enfermedad
renal
que fue haciendo que ellos envejecieran
antes que mi edad biológica
y así fue que en 2005 me diagnosticaron
una insuficiencia renal leve en el 2013
fines del 2013
ya era una insuficiencia renal crónica
se preguntarán ustedes que es una
insuficiencia renal y crónica
es cuando nuestros riñones dejan de
funcionar y crónica porque es un estadio
de la enfermedad que es irreversible
en el 2014 comencé con diálisis
peritoneal
que era diálisis
desconectarme una máquina y que se
realice la función que es mis riñones no
estaban realizando
pero fui yo la que me acerqué a mi
médico a decirle que necesitaba comenzar
a realizar
ustedes deben preguntar qué sentía
insomnio decaimiento general falta de
apetito
alucinaciones
y cada mañana me miraba al espejo
y esa imagen que el espejo me devolvía
no era yo
me desconocía
y les puedo asegurar
que ese fue el momento en que conocí el
verdadero sentido de la frase sentirme
mal
y cuántas veces la había dicho sin
realmente conocer lo que era sentirme
mal
y la palabra trasplante apareció
entonces empezamos en familia a
transitar este largo y duro camino que
teníamos por delante
si bien para mí no era una frase o una
situación en la que yo nunca hubiese
pensado
es más viéndolo hoy después de todo lo
vivido creo que la vida misma me fue
preparando para la persona que soy hoy
y si si ustedes me preguntan si lo
volvería a pasar
aunque mi mamá que está acá se enoje
lo volvería a pasar
porque creo que soy hoy
la persona interior que me gusta hacer
y a partir de ahí comencé a ayudar a
personas que estaban en situaciones
peores a la mía
yo me conectaba a una máquina durante 10
horas
todos los días
casi medio día
pero hay órganos
que por el momento
no tienen reemplazo por una máquina
hasta que llega a su trasplante
hígado médula ósea
entonces fue que así llegamos a lo que
es la donación
todos estamos seguros y vamos a
coincidir en algo sabemos lo bueno
necesario
qué es recibir un trasplante
pero yo le pregunto a ustedes son
donantes
no se preocupen no les voy a pedir que
levanten la mano pero muchos dirían que
no
por miedo
mitos
y el más común
no se te ocurra decir que esos donantes
menos lo dejes por escrito porque si te
pasa algo y estás con vida te van a
llevar al hospital y te van a matar
como podemos pensar
que un médico que se preparó toda su
vida para salvar vidas
va a matar a uno para salvar a otros
y todo esto pasa por falta de
información
entonces comencé a trabajar sobre
la concientización y sobre una idea
básica
si no hay información
no hay donación
y si no hay donación no hay trasplantes
y si no hay trasplantes gentes no hay
vida
contarles que cuando cualquiera de
nosotros necesitamos un trasplante no
importa nuestra posición económica
no importa si nos atendemos en un lugar
público en un lugar privado
si somos médicos políticos
cantantes
o cualquiera de nosotros todos formamos
parte de la misma lista de espera
y este trasplante va a ser abonado o
cubierto por el estado obra social
o prepaga
en la argentina
en este momento hay aproximadamente
11.000 personas en lista de espera
escucharon 11.000 personas en lista de
espera
tres mil para córneas
8000 para órganos
de esos ocho mil ochocientos
mueren
por año esperando esa segunda
oportunidad de vida
de los cuales 240
son niños
entonces
les voy a hacer un ejemplo para que
ustedes puedan tomar dimensión de lo que
es este número del que estamos hablando
en la guerra de malvinas murieron 649
personas y si es como si tuviésemos una
guerra cada año
malvinas no lo podemos cambiar
pero a esto sí podemos cambiarlo
con una acción desinteresada
altruista y anónima
que nos remite al más primordial de los
vínculos entre los seres humanos
a una acción denominada dar
los órganos la sangre la médula ósea por
el momento no se fabrican en ningún lado
dependemos de cada uno de nosotros de
nuestros pares
por eso yo les pido que miremos a la
persona que tenemos al lado mírenla por
favor
y así poder comprender
que tenemos más posibilidad de necesitar
un trasplante que de ser donantes
más allá de estar mi vida dependiendo de
esa
decisión que tomaré una persona en vida
más allá de eso yo seguía teniendo
esperanza fuerza que me regalo de vida
llegaría
y sería el mejor
y para eso me preparaba cada día
como les dije antes
conectándome 10 horas todos los días
rigurosamente no me importaba nada
y a pesar de eso seguía trabajando y
creando conciencia sobre la donación de
órganos
y hacer que cada una de las personas a
cuántas yo podía le pudiera expresar que
había gente que estaba esperando córneas
para poder ver por primera vez a sus
hijos
para ver por primera vez el amanecer
otros esperando pulmones
para poder respirar algo tan simple y
tan complejos como esos y otros
esperando un corazón
para poder sentir a cada paso su latir
entonces me pregunto
porque los seres humanos somos tan
complicados
porque siempre estamos pendientes y le
damos valor a lo que no tenemos
y no le damos el verdadero valor a todo
lo que tenemos
y ese día llegó
les seguirán día
de octubre
del 2015
recibí el llamado tan esperado
esta segunda en lista de espera
y al lado de la tarde
me lo confirmaron
tu regalo de vida sigo
y todos me preguntan que sentí en ese
momento sentí una alegría tan inmensa
que no me entraba en el cuerpo
y rompí en santo
y mi marido
pensó que yo había entrado en pánico y
que no lo iba a querer
dije cómo podéis pensar que no lo voy a
querer si me preparé cada día cada
instante para recibir ese regalo
y les puedo asegurar que no pasa un solo
día que no piense en mi ángel donante
y en su familia
que respecto
esa voluntad que él tuvo en vida
por eso es que les quiero pedir que cada
uno
exprese esa voluntad en vida que no se
la deje a sus familiares para que la
tomen por ustedes en un momento tan
difícil como es la pérdida de un ser
querido
y en homenaje a él es que llevo adelante
la casa del donante la única en el país
y trabajamos creando conciencia ayudando
a pacientes que están en lista de espera
a trasplantados y a sus familiares a
poder atravesar momentos difíciles y a
compartir con ellos alegría cuando llega
su ángel donante
también concientizamos en cada una de
las instituciones de nuestra ciudad
llevando el mensaje
que detrás de cada donación lo único que
hay es vida
que intervienen más de 120 personas
y que solo es posible ser donante si
fallece moss en una terapia intensiva y
con muerte cerebral
es decir si yo sufre un accidente de
tránsito y muero en ese lugar mis
órganos no pueden ser donados
solamente podemos donar tejidos córneas
válvulas cardíacas piel y huesos
se trabaja contrarreloj
y detrás de todo este procedimiento está
cudaio incucai que son los que llevan
adelante todo
sabemos que falta mucho
pero nuestra ciudad
ya comenzamos a construir una sociedad
donante
y queda demostrado con cada una de las
colectas que llevamos adelante de sangre
buscando ese cambio de paradigma que la
sangre espera al paciente y no el
paciente a la sangre
el cambio está en nosotros
sabemos que diciendo soy donante
salvamos hasta siete personas
y ayudamos a que dejen de sobrevivir
para comenzar a vivir
donar es el acto de amor más grande que
puede existir de un ser humano a otro
nunca sabemos de qué lado nos va a tocar
estar
se los puedo asegurar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]